Okay, so now, talking about content, we need to expand our keyword list.
The reason why we do that is because we want to have as many keywords as possible when
we're writing content, that way we're not using the same keywords over and over.
And we want to have an expanded, nice keyword list for each website and each project we're
going into.
So we personally use Basecamp.
We don't necessarily recommend it, we got a free account for it, so that's why we're
using it.
But again, as long as you have, wherever you're keeping your keyword list, just make sure
you're making a copy and you're putting this under your website that we're going after.
So in my case, it would be Queen Creek, Arizona, Concrete.
And this is the keyword list, okay?
So we usually have about 20 to 30 keywords, and this is the very basic list for Concrete.
Now I'm sure this is going to look different than your Concrete list.
And again, like we said earlier, when we were building the website, Concrete is a little
broad and a lot of companies will do different things.
Some companies do coding, other companies do not do crack repair.
So just make sure you're checking in with your client and follow up on what it is they're
doing.
Usually the main services are going to be stamped concrete, concrete driveway, and concrete
patios.
So those are the ones that you want to focus on most of the time.
These numbers right here that you see, these are taken from SEMrush.
So we use SEMrush, as I said before, you don't need to use it as well.
It's just what we are using.
You can use whatever you want.
And so what we do is we actually plug in each keyword that we have and we see what the volume
in search is just to get an idea on, okay, maybe stamp concrete is super important to
put in our content, right?
Because it seems like it's the most search out of all of them.
And then concrete driveway, it's pretty well searched.
Concrete patios as well.
So that's why we do that, just to kind of get an idea.
So go ahead and plug that in.
And then after you have your basic one, make sure you also put your location.
So concrete companies in blah, blah, blah, New York, Queen Creek, wherever you are trying
to rank.
Okay.
After that, you are going to pick, in our case, our homepage was like concrete contractors,
concrete company.
So I already went ahead and expanded the concrete contractor keyword.
So what I usually do is I actually highlight the, I would say between five to eight keywords
that I'm going to expand on, okay?
So this is usually a short tail keyword, which means it's short tail.
Like I said, very short.
And then there's a long tail keywords and they're both important when it comes down
to ranking.
They're just different.
So a long tail keyword would be like in a full, like a lengthy one.
For example, how much does roof repair cost?
That's a long tail keyword.
And so that's why we like to expand them because we want to try, the whole purpose is to write
a content that includes things that people are searching for.
And people that need a concrete driveway, most of the time will not just type in Google
concrete driveway.
They're going to type something like concrete driveway pricing near me.
And that is a long tail keyword.
So that's what most people are searching for, especially if people are like on their phone
talking to Siri or anything, they tend to be more lengthy.
So that's why it's important to include short tail keywords and long tail keywords because
most of the time people are typing something more lengthy when they're looking for a service.
And so I'm just going to highlight the keywords that I am going to expand.
So we already did concrete contractor.
I'm going to show you another one.
Let's do concrete driveway.
And usually you want to probably put this in order of importance.
So I would probably put this concrete driveway up here since it's something that I want.
Oops.
Okay, there you go.
And now let's expand concrete driveway.
All right, so now enter and tab, okay.
So how do how we do this?
Once you kind of get the hang of it, you're going to do the same things like you're going
to know that an extension to the concrete driveway concrete patio is going to be like
near me cost residential.
Like some of some of the extensions are always the same.
So they're reoccurring.
So you'll know.
But one thing that it's really easy and I really like to do is just get into the Google
search down here and just type concrete driveway and it's really nice because Google will tell
you will give you ideas, will give you suggestions on where people are searching.
And I like to put a space and then just start with the first letter of the alphabet.
So I put a.
Okay, we don't care for apron alternatives edition and patio.
Okay, average cost could be something and think, think as if you were someone looking
for this service.
So think of, okay, I bought a house, I need a concrete driveway.
What would I search if I had a buying intent on Google?
Okay, average cost seems like someone who is looking to buy.
Okay, nothing else really came to my head more than that.
So let's start with B base border breaking up room finish base preparation.
And again, I would rather put a lot of options there and then you can, it's always faster
to edit and cancel things out other than adding them on later.
So I'm not sure if base preparation, it's more of a DIY things that someone would do
on his own, but we can put that in there and then we'll, we'll do a little more research.
see cost contractors cost per square foot crack repair.
I'm sure there's company and these are kind of already knowing because I've done this
before and companies near me contractors near me.
And again, concrete driveway contractors and concrete driving contractors near me.
They are technically two different long tail keywords.
One is more expensive than the other.
See coding, crack filler and cost calculator.
Cost calculator is a really good one because that really means that someone is wanting
a quote mostly I'm already forgetting crack filler and coding.
Okay, then I put a D designs could be one.
We definitely do not want to put anything that it's DIY other than the only way you
can talk about DIY stuff is if you're saying we do not recommend doing DIY because you
can cause more damage and it's going to end up costing more.
So you could put designs because especially if the contractor is offering stamped concrete,
that may be a good way to kind of showcase the stamped concrete and the kind of design
they can do on the driveway.
Entrance again, think as a buyer, think of you really need or if you can come up with
ideas, ask, ask a friend, ask a family member, say, hey, if you were looking to get a driveway,
what would you search on Google?
What would you, you know, and get ideas that way finishes.
You probably want to stick away from financing.
We're probably okay doing whole repair again.
Those are like uncertain.
You can even highlight in like a yellow or a green to make sure that you do check in
with the owner of the company if they do actually do coating or, or repair.
Installation installers near me, installation cost.
You can even throw like concrete driveway.
You can put Queen Creek in my case.
You can put like your location, your state, I think I'm missing installation cost.
Leveling, lifting again, you're really wanting to make sure that the company that you're
working for does this.
We definitely want to put them in there and then just highlight them.
You could put makeover.
Seems like someone who's doing maybe a new installation.
Near me, options, overlay.
Okay, I think I already put near me.
Nope, I did not.
Okay.
Options near me is always going to be one of the options for most keywords.
Options near me, overlay, overlay cost on a slope.
Pavers, price per square foot, paving.
The reason why we're putting so many extensions is because when people are searching on Google
something, Google takes people to certain websites because they are trying to match
the intent of what that person is searching to the best results that make answer that question.
If that makes sense.
So the reason why we want to expand and kind of cover as many questions and there's many
options and possibilities because we want to try to gather everyone in the area of Queen Creek.
For us, could be New York or Los Angeles, looking for anything, any of these services to us.
So not just driveway and patio.
We want to gather anyone looking for an installation.
Maybe they are looking for stamped concrete, but they're typing installation.
Maybe they're typing makeover.
So we want to really gather everyone and that's why we expand the keyword list and we try to
anyone that has a buyer intent in that location we want to get.
Repair, rest facing, repair near me, replacement.
Repair near me, replacement.
Again, make sure like something like rest facing.
Not everyone does that.
so make sure that your company actually covers that.
Sealer sounds, I would put Sealing Near Me. Sealer sounds like someone that is trying to
buy something from those. DIY, Sealing Near Me sounds more like a service that needs to get done.
Types, types could be a good option like someone is looking and
you know types could go into stamp and here are the options.
Quotes, quotes near me.
I'm forgetting one letter we're on.
Queen Creek, if I haven't put that in there, I already put it.
You could put vendors.
Okay I think we got most of what we wanted. Okay and that is how you expand a keyword list. Now
you're going to do that. I would usually do whatever we end up doing, putting in the H1
and we'll cover that later when we do on-page SEO. Whatever you want to really cover as a service
page. So remember when we built a website we had a home page. Service page was concrete driveway,
concrete patio, stamped concrete. So I really want to expand concrete driveway.
My next one would probably be stamped concrete right here and the other one concrete patio.
And then I would probably do also concrete company and that's it. So I'm going to highlight these so
you can see them. I would do concrete contractor, concrete driveway, concrete company. These are
the ones that I would expand stamped concrete and again it's just based on what your services
are going to focus. Anything that is going to need like content for you, you want to expand.
And that will make writing content a lot easier because once you write content on this page you're
going to have all of these options to write about. And that is it.